game off Charlotte Durant shooting over
Batu's an impossible shot to the heart
yeah well we all know that the two-plus
shot blocked let's see you get a more
active on people in the feint and then
you've got just way more than 29 minutes
bass goes to cook cook again left open
and knocks it down he's been shooting
extremely well playing in the G Lee and
Andre you doll I come in as Durant
drives down tough fall away shot is good
and 9 early points for Kevin Durant way
let's come down now to take high
percentage shots Caspi out to Durant
Durant wide open while you could see the
double-team they took away to drive
their first team all-nba to Leslie and
one of the great two-way players and
then speaking about two ways now this
guy we all know that he's a great scorer
thing you learn as a coach when you have
a 7-foot guy who can score down inside
where you please pass on the ball you
don't pass on the ball all of a sudden
the rebound in the shot blocking I'm not
there smattering it's been very ragged
offensive performance klay Thompson
drills the three pointer and the lead is
now ballooned to 26 but they lead the
league at 29 foul shot attempts a game
they're 1 for 1 they've attempted one
foul shot Durant now at 22 to set up and
execute against their half-court defense
it's impossible if the ball doesn't move
to beat this Golden State Warriors team
guys this year shooting 50% 86% forty
seven point three as Durant wide open 3
pointer knocks it down
and then you add Klay Thompson's
defending above crazy Walker drives shot
blocked
tried to draw the foul
it's that good help defense Durant so
west running the floor throws it down
yeah that's where they hurt you
keep an eye here right now this is just
a great pass by Durant good connection
[Applause]
Thompson
while difficult shot he gets it to go
back to 12 again you behind you right
there like I told you they cake cake
cake as good as they are but you gotta
grab the game there comes Durant Durant
29 point since 25 minutes
nice feed McGee the trailer and an easy
bucket that's what you love here they
come again
Durant throws it up for McGee
he's making the ghee look good here and
there McGee if he would have from the
offensive end of the floor now the
hesitation but to pass now we say that
the pass is there that also very quietly
the first quarter is seventh Thompson
off the screen drills the three pointer
and Kevin Durant with that pass as a
triple-double